well here's a question that's not
totally related but you might be a good
person for this what is quantum
computing now I keep hearing about this
that's one of the big breakthroughs in
computers is going to be quantum
computing right I'm almost the right guy
I'm not completely the regular I
actually did teach a course at Cal Tech
that involve quantum computing so I'm
above average so so quantum mechanics
this is the book that I'm writing right
now that's gonna be out a year from now
called something deeply hidden it'll be
about quantum mechanics and the goal of
the book will be to make quantum
mechanics understandable to everybody
and convince them that quantum mechanics
really does imply the existence of
multiple worlds where things look very
much the same except for tiny
differences and one way to think about
what quantum mechanics says is in
classical mechanics which is what came
before quantum mechanics let's imagine
you have a bit right that is something
is either 0 or 1 right one piece of
information in quantum mechanics you
have a quantum bit a qubit as they call
it very clever so the difference is that
instead of it being a 0 or a 1
like it would be classically quantum
mechanically it is in some superposition
of 0 and 1 and some combination of a
little bit 0 a little bit 1 and it's not
that you don't know which one it is it's
that it really is both it might be 90% 0
and 10% 1 or something like that so take
that fact number 1 ok
fact number 2 is that quantum mechanics
says the thing called entanglement which
means that if you have two bits
classically so you have 0 0 0 1 1 0 1 1
right for different possibilities so
quantum mechanics says it's not that
this one bit is in a combination of 0
and 1 and this other bit is also in a
combination of 0 and 1 it's that the two
bit system is in a combination of 0 0 0
1 1 0 1 1 right so it might be that is
50% 0 0 and 50% 1 1 so you don't know
what either bit is but you know they're
the same right so that's entanglement so
you take these two ideas that you have a
combination of zeros and ones rather
than just one or the other and the
different bits can be in
tangled with each other and then you
just say well what is a computer
computer something he takes bits in does
manipulations and spits out the answer
right you solve problems you that's
what's literally going on in your
computer is a bunch of zeros and ones
being pushed around so a quantum
computer is pushing around a bunch of
qubits right bunch of spinning particles
or something like that the spin of a
particle that can either be spinning
clockwise or counter clockwise is a
qubit and so these particles can
interact with each other they can become
entangled and you invent a quantum
algorithm right like there's algorithms
for you know finding the area of a
surface or something like that factoring
large numbers you know solving the
shortest distance between two different
points you can do this using the rules
of quantum mechanics instead of the
rules of classical mechanics and the
belief which is not yet 100% established
but we think is true is that there are
some problems that are really really
hard to solve for a classical computer
which means that you can easily make the
problem long enough that it would take
the lifetime of the universe to solve it
on a classical computer which quantum
computers can solve quite quickly and
efficiently and so it's we're not we
haven't proven that it's not
mathematically why is this why would
they think that quantum computers would
be able to solve it quicker
there's more information in the quantum
computer like if you have two bits 0 0 0
1 etc there's only four things it can be
right if you have a quantum computers an
infinite number of things that can be
because it's any combination of those
four things right 10 present this 20%
that so there's like a continuum of
possibilities it's it's analog rather
than digital in some sense and so what
you what you can do you know the quantum
computer can just sort of take advantage
of that extra power to look I mean
because of this entanglement what this
is this is I'm gonna get in trouble with
my quantum computing friends because not
quite fair but roughly speaking rather
than manipulating bit by bit because of
the entanglement between the bits the
quantum computer can move all the bits a
little bit at once so let's say that
you're you're searching for something in
a list right a very elementary computer
science program is I'm giving you a list
find an element that is equal to a
certain number right
it sounds easy but if that list is ten
trillion things long that's hard right
so what the quantum computer can do is
say take every element in the list nudge
it a little bit towards zero if it's the
wrong answer and towards one if it's the
right answer and you don't know where it
is in the list but you can do that
nudging over and over again at the end
of the day look for where is the one
it's very easy to find so you can get
the answer much quicker it is believed
and so things like cryptography privacy
right are dramatically changed by this
because if one of the things that we
think quantum computers should be able
to do faster is factor large numbers
which is the the the difficulty in
factoring large numbers is the basis for
much modern cryptography but also
simulating systems that were just too
difficult to simulate you know just just
it took too much computer power to do it
now maybe we can do it because nature is
truly quantum mechanical at the core it
turns out to be very hard because the
problem is you have all these bits if
you touch one of them if the outside
world bumps into one of them right like
a cosmic ray or atom hits it the whole
entanglement is ruined between
everything so it's very very delicate
and that's what the you know right now
they're they're working on systems of
let's say dozens of qubits entangled at
once you would you would like it to be
way more than that because you can store
an enormous amount of information in
these things and if it works as I think
it'll be way better at computing if it
works I'm not at all sure that quantum
computers will be efficient or
cost-effective or anything like that in
the near term but you know doing
computations faster something's a lot of
people want to be able to do